comme le disait voltaire il faut savoir
cultiver son jardin et ça patricia
laigneau l'a bien compris
[Musique]
tellement beau pour la chose que il faut
absolument veiller à ce que tous les
gens qui l'inertie soit irrigué au
château du rivau c'est elle la patronne
des 6 hectares fleury il y à fort à
faire si les touristes sont absents
depuis plus de cinq mois
la nature elle n'attend pas avec ses 20
jardiniers la propriétaire des lieux
bichonne les narcisses muscaris et
autres anémone blanda déjà en pleine
floraison
on aime ce jardin on a envie qu'eux ils
deviennent de plus en plus beau au fur
et à mesure des soins coin de la porte
et c'est très important quand même
économiquement parlant parce que
autrement la jour on pourra plus rester
ouverts on pourra plus payer toutes les
personnes qui travaillent ici et il faut
absolument donc qu'il soit vu par le
maximum des visiteurs avec la fermeture
à répétition depuis plus d'un an
la famille laigneau a vu son chiffre
d'affaires baisser de 35% en 2020 une
urgence donc de retrouver le public les
fêtes de pâques était l'occasion toute
trouvée jeu d'énigmes distribution de
chocolats l'équipe de médiation avait
tout prévu pour la réouverture des
jardins dès ce jeudi 1er avril
cette prophétie les visiteurs seront
plutôt en autonomie avec le luxe avec le
quelques indications sur l'importation
d'accord mais l'annoncé d'un troisième
confinement nationale a obligé patricia
les new et sa fille a refermé une
nouvelle fois les portes du château ce
week end
deux jours seulement après avoir
retrouvé un semblant d'activité
touristique
un véritable coup dur de voir cette
période de l'année qui est tellement
merveilleuse avec le jardin qui commence
à respirer qui se réveille et de pas
pouvoir ans pour faire profiter
les visiteurs de voir tout ce travail
qu'on a fait pendant l'hiver qui n'avait
pas été mis en avant c'est difficile
pour les équipes parce que tout le monde
se donne du mal on a la chance d'avoir
des équipes assez soudé et on se sent
inutile donc c'est très dur douche
froide aussi du côté du château de
langeais les visiteurs attendront encore
avant de revoir les séquoias et les
cèdres bicentenaire du parc de 5
hectares mais malgré cet énième coup de
frein pas de mise en veille pour la
forteresse médiévale
ici on pense déjà à la suite on a
beaucoup de projets qu'on met en place
pour la saison 2010 21 un nouveau
spectacle sur le mariage de charles
guité d'anne de bretagne une l'ouverture
d'une nouvelle salle aussi sur l'art du
tissage et puis et puis il faut
entretenir ce lieu aussi bien les
intérieurs il ya le grand ménage qu'on
fait chaque hiver et puis en extérieur
aussi la la la nature se réveille là et
donc il faut tondre il faut tailler les
haies il faut s'occuper aussi du jardin
et du parc
langeais rivaux valence et villandry ou
encore azay le rideau pour ses châteaux
de la loire les vacances d'avril sonné
comme une délivrance
tous espèrent un retour à la normale
mi-mai pour prouver aux visiteurs que
chez eux le temps ne s'est jamais arrêté